[Musica]
siate unici
siate veri siate felici
so che vi state chiedendo se sono ancora
nel possesso delle mie facoltà mentali o
sei studiare troppo un po ha compromesso
il mio essere qui oggi
in realtà ci chiediamo come facciamo a
essere unici in un mondo che ci vuole
tutti uguali stereotipati addomesticati
come possiamo essere veri in un mondo
che confonde l'apparenza con la sostanza
come possiamo essere felici
in un mondo che ci vuole in costante
competizione l'uno verso l'altro per
alcuni la vita è una strada a un inizio
un percorso e una fine per altri la vita
è un insieme di punti è un insieme di
momenti
ecco per me è la seconda perlomeno oggi
sono qui proprio perché vorrei aver
avuto la saggezza di aspettare tutti
quei punti
avete presente come nella settimana
enigmistica i punti sono tutte le
bisogna unirli è vedere che cosa viene
fuori
ecco la vita non funziona così la vita
ti dai punti e solo dopo un po di tempo
riusciamo a vedere l'immagine che ne
viene fuori è a volte non abbiamo la
pazienza di aspettare a volte non
abbiamo la saggezza di sapere che il
significato arriverà più avanti
dopo che abbiamo vissuto alcuni
avvenimenti e la nostra vita prenderà il
significato e le avremmo dato proprio
durante l'aver l'ha vissuta
semplicemente condivido con voi alcuni
dei miei punti
i più fondamentali quelli che avrei
voluto ascoltare io perché forse mi
avrebbero dato più pazienza forse mi
avrebbero dato più saggezza
forse mi avrebbero reso la vita non più
facile ma più semplice e mi avrebbero
portato forse a viverla
con più calma con più serenità con più
tranquillità e ad andare oltre con
pazienza
ecco allora io parto da una famiglia
molto semplice
ho avuto un'infanzia molto serena forse
proprio perché è molto semplice
figlia di genitori immigrati sì mi sono
trovata veramente a vivere un'infanzia
dove il problema maggiore era non farsi
beccare dalla mamma a mangiare i
cioccolatini dietro l'albero di natale
riempiendoli di domopak oppure a non
farsi beccare mentre bevevamo il poveri
pulivamo i bicchierini col dito
ecco è una realtà è una è un punto di
partenza è una famiglia semplice mia
mamma ci ha cresciuto dicendoci come ti
ho fatto ti disco questa casa non è un
albergo finisci tutto quello che c'è nel
piatto perché in africa e bambini
muoiono e mio padre mi ha cresciuto e ha
cresciuto me e mia sorella
proprio in che modo alzando sempre
l'asticella quando tornavo a casa tutta
felice dicendo papà papà ho preso sette
perché non sette e mezzo ho preso sette
e mezzo perché non 8 ma perché ho preso
otto e mezzo perché non 9 quindi capite
che sono veramente è cresciuta con
l'idea che veramente bisogna impegnarsi
bisogna sempre andare oltre da piccoli
avevamo poco ma non ci mancava nulla
come potete vedere mia mamma è di quelle
persone che ci ha insegnato a utilizzare
i vestiti finché potevamo e i vestiti
cieli passavamo non solo tra me e mia
sorella ma contatti che mio papà se ti
fratelli mamma uguale quindi anche tra i
cugini siamo figli di quelle tavolate di
natale
questa è la realtà nella quale sono
cresciuta nella quale ho vissuto proprio
i miei primi passi fino a quando fino al
maggio del 1985 dove nel giorno in cui
vincevo la mia prima medaglia d'oro a
dorso mia mamma veniva operata veniva
operata nel secondo aneurisma cerebrale
edi è rimasta invalida ha scelto poi di
diventare ombre l'aia per curarci per
crescerci per poterci stare vicino e
fino a quel giorno la mia infanzia era
serena e da quel momento la realtà è
completamente cambiata la mia realtà
quello in cui sognavo quello che speravo
speravo di continuare a studiare speravo
di poter diventare un medico se proprio
non potevo permettermi medicina magari
psicologia perché con le persone a me
piaceva tantissimo starci
ecco quella realtà è cambiata in un
momento pur non c'era più nulla
quella è stata la mia nuova realtà che
cosa ho deciso ovviamente il passo
successivo era scegliere una scuola e
quindi ho scelto ragioniere
programmatore perché ragioneria puoi
andare a lavorare anche senza fare
l'università anche se so che mio padre
avrebbe fatto di tutto per farmi
studiare ho fatto una scelta
diplomata classe 1991 inizia a cercare
lavoro e li provo tutti inizia a
lavorare al mattino per cui dalle 7 alle
9 portavo un bambino all'asilo e mi
prendevo cura della sua colazione dalle
11 alle 13 dama di compagnia e poi dalle
16 alle 18 ripetizioni ho fatto di tutto
perché lavorare
era importante in quel periodo ho
portato avanti tutte le emozioni gioia
tristezza rabbia entusiasmo curiosità ho
utilizzato ogni emozione che la vita mi
ha dato
e poi sono riuscito a entrare in banca
uno dei miei primi sogni realizzati gli
anni migliori della mia vita mi sono
divertita tantissimo
sì lo so sembra strano ma in realtà in
banca ti puoi anche divertire
ho vissuto degli anni stupendi sono
entrati in quella che allora era la
banca popolare credito varesino pensate
calabrese nella banca popolare di
bergamo
unica donna in mezzo a 22 colleghi è la
più giovane della filiale gli anni
migliori della mia vita veramente
utilizzato di tutto sono stati anche gli
anni della scoperta ho scoperto la mia
passione per la formazione prima da
allieva nel 1994 il primo corso serale a
cui mi sono iscritta di tecniche di
vendita e grazie a vittorio serantoni il
mio mentore ho incontrato la formazione
come docente sono diventata docente
interno
ho vissuto degli anni meravigliosi
lavoravo e studiavo studiavo e lavoravo
la mia idea personale di paradiso per
qualche per qualcuno studiare per me è
sempre stato importante perché il sapere
e il saper fare e il saper far fare sono
le leve che guidano la mia vita oggi lo
so e mi ritorna tanto in mente quella
frase che mi dissero proprio in questo
periodo e che ancora ritorna dopo quasi
30 anni
ma andiamo avanti prevenzione che cosa
mi doveva insegnare ancora la vita che
devi essere consapevole della direzione
di dove sta andando la tua strada
ho cambiato lavoro quando mi hanno detto
per essere una donna 6 fin troppo avanti
il punto è che lo facevano con dei buoni
propositi era una semplice constatazione
ho cambiato lavoro non per andare verso
quello che volevo fare
ma per andare via da quello che temevo
da quello che non sopportavo più
ecco la vita doveva insegnarmi proprio
questo che una direzione una strada non
è uguale alle altre che andare verso
quello che per noi è importante è molto
meglio che preoccuparci di quello che
temiamo la vita continua cambio lavoro
di vento formatore e mi e volvo entrò in
un'azienda dove per sette anni cambio
ruolo lavoro capi attività cambio di
tutto pensate che mi hanno proprio
cambiato tantissimo nel modo di pensare
nel modo di accogliere la vita
nell'andare alla scoperta sono gli anni
più belli lavorativi perché faccio anche
un'esperienza all'estero riesco a
realizzare quel sogno di uscire da
quello che era il mio bozzolo conoscere
persone nuove
mi trovo a bruxelles e il 2006 siamo
un'italiana un greco uno spagnolo e un
turco non è un
la barzelletta in realtà è un gruppo che
veramente mi cambierà la vita
un'esperienza che mi cambierà la vita e
che mi farà prendere una strada
completamente diversa
torno in italia ed ecco che diventa
importante comprendere un aspetto
fondamentale
ero riuscita ad arrivare ad essere
responsabile della formazione il lavoro
della mia vita e dall'oggi al domani
nel giro di tre giorni dal 2 giugno 2009
al 5 giugno 2009 la mia vita cambia di
nuovo perché l'azienda per la quale
lavoro chiude e al 31 di agosto ci
lasciano tutti a casa ecco che per me
diventa importante ricrearli rinascere
rimboccarmi le maniche aprire la partita
iva e iniziare a lavorare come formatore
e grazie alle connessioni grazie alle
persone grazie alle relazioni sono
riuscite a partire con una carriera
tutta nuova che seguiva una strada un
percorso che ancora non conoscevo
sarebbe stata la strada che mi ha
portato veramente ad essere me stessa
veramente ad essere felice
ed ecco che è importante comprendere
quale tipo di trasformazione la vita ti
dà ed è continua la trasformazione ci ho
messo dieci anni a diventare psicologa
positiva sono andata fino a londra e in
10 anni
la trasformazione è stata evidente a
livello mentale fisico emotivo ma alla
fine ce l'ho fatta ho realizzato un
altro sogno e mi tornava sempre in mente
quella frase che mi era mia stata detta
quasi trent'anni fa andavo avanti lo
stesso
ecco quello che voglio condividere con
voi e come ho unito i punti perché
perché tre elementi la mia vita è stata
3d desiderio disciplina e determinazione
una volta che ho capito qual era il mio
desiderio una volta che ho capito qual
era la mia strada
tutto il resto si è formato da solo e
vorrei tantissimo aver avuto qualcuno
che mi dicesse queste parole la realtà
da cui partì è l'unica nella quale tu
sei il nostro cervello riceve 11 milioni
di vite di informazione al secondo
ma noi ne percepiamo soltanto 40 11
milioni e 40 ecco che la realtà cela
costruiamo le emozioni le proverai tutte
accogliere quelle gradevoli usa le come
energia per sostenerti le altre per
spronarti perché tutte hanno una
funzione tutte sono importanti apriti
alla scoperta apriti al diverso apriti a
chi la pensa in maniera differente da te
perché questo farà la differenza nella
tua vita aprirti agli altri alla
diversità alla contaminazione positiva
prevenzione
vai verso ciò che ami invece che
scappare da ciò che temi questo è
importantissimo perché una
consapevolezza che davvero cambia la
vita davvero ti cambia la strada che
puoi scegliere l'evoluzione è naturale
diventa complessa diventa difficili solo
quando noi la allontaniamo quando la
respingiamo quando non la accettiamo
quando temiamo le persone che siamo
destinati a diventare le connessioni se
mi avessero detto che le relazioni sono
le persone insieme all'ottimismo e alla
capacità di gestire le sfide che dà la
vera felicità mi avrebbero davvero
cambiato la vita
e in ultimo la trasformazione perché noi
continuiamo a trasformarci continuerò la
mia strada e tutti questi elementi mi
danno oggi veramente le parole per
rispondere a quella famosa frase mi
state chiedendo cosa mi è stato detto è
stato detto che nella vita si fa
carriera solo se sei di buona famiglia e
anche questa era una constatazione
volevano semplicemente dirmi che non
partivo dallo stesso punto
ebbene io oggi quello che dico è e
quello che direi a quella stessa persona
è nella vita la strada che farai sarà
quella che deciderai di fare
l'importante che sia tu a che la
desideri tu che sia veramente la tua
direzione personale ed è veramente
importante a questo punto chiedersi cosa
farà la differenza nella tua vita ciò
che farai
differente ed è per questo che vi invito
a essere veri essere unici e a essere
felici con la vostra strada